[Musik]
ein wunderschöner nachmittag erwartet
uns hier in unserer kleinen süßen
minecraft fällt meine lieben freunde der
ein oder andere wird sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich bei dem titel denken hey
luca das ist folge 98 hier gerade nicht
folge 99 weil ich selber in den letzten
episoden gesagt habe dass in der
heutigen episode 98 wir uns auf das ende
vorbereiten dann in folge 99 das beste
auf minecraft beta kommt und in folge
100 dass dann die letzte episode sein
wird wo wir uns ende gehen die sache ist
allerdings dass ich mir darüber noch mal
gedanken gemacht habe und mir einfach
gedacht habe mensch es macht gar keinen
sinn wenn wir in der heutigen episode
uns fürs ende vorbereiten dann in der
nächsten episode uns das beste auf
angucken und dann müssen wir wieder da
hinten hin zum stronghold oder cent
portal war deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
mensch verschieden war das beste auf
minecraft mit luca einfach mal auf heute
und da habe ich wirklich zu unfassbar
kranken bock drauf denn ein kumpel von
mir habe ich euch auch schon gesagt hat
sich alle episoden minecraft mit luke
heruntergeladen ich nehme mal ganz kurz
meine knochen macht die zu klopfen mir
und bringen diese karotten jetzt um
wachsen das ist ja unfassbar wie lange
brauchen ja nicht ablenken lassen luca
ein kollege von mir hat die alle
episoden mit luca runtergeladen und die
besten lustigsten traurigsten
interessantesten spannendsten szenen
rausgepickt und daraus einen fast 30
minuten langes video zusammengeschnitten
was wir uns gleich zusammen anschauen
werden der ein oder andere hat mir in
die kommentare geschrieben lukas wäre
richtig richtig geil wenn du eine
leinwand dafür bauen würde finde ich
selber auch immer noch cool die idee die
sache das allerdings dass wir dafür auf
der einen seite nicht so richtig die
zeit haben weil das beste auf hat schon
so lang geht und auf der anderen seite
habe ich mal gedacht mensch wir haben
halt immer noch unsere kranke netflix
videoleinwand da hinten in unserem
unsere kassen der strandhaus bilder
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht laufen wir
da jetzt einfach mal hin rüber wir sehen
schon die sonne geht langsam unter von
daher sind wir auf jeden fall perfekt in
der zeit so dass wir einen entspannten
netflix abend hinten machen können und
ja nicht wie gespannt ich bin nicht
nehmen hier vorne zweifach der die
abkürzung des gar keinen sinn dass ich
da vorne diesen weg rechts gebaut habe
die sache ist allerdings dass ich
richtig bock habe mir das mit euch
zusammen anzugucken ich hoffe das
einfach mal während wir uns das zusammen
angucken jetzt das bisher nacht und ich
hoffe dass in der zeit dann noch ein
phantom spot dann wäre es wirklich ein
absolut geiler episode weil wir dann
einerseits das beste auf haben und noch
ein phantom von dem wir dann hoffentlich
die phantome haut bekommen so dass wir
uns halt einen geilen trank noch fürs
ende machen können für vor 100 oder
flipper gerade unten naja freunde
ich bin total halb denn jetzt kommen die
besten szenen aus den letzten 98 folgen
film ab
[Musik]
ich habe ab und keine ahnung wie ich das
heutige video hier starten soll der
letzte nacht habe ich geträumt ich werde
wieder im jahr 2016
und hat sich aufgewacht bin hatte ich
dann so einen kleinen
ich will dich nervenzusammenbruch nennen
das wäre völlig übertrieben aber ich
habe auf einmal alles infrage gestellt
und hab mich irgendwie nach der alten
zeit so ein bisschen zurück gesehen und
was auf youtube bezogen die alte zeit
für mich bedeutet ist einfach minecraft
ich habe mir heute wirklich einfach
gedacht ich habe lust auf minecraft ich
will wieder dieses spielhallen ich hab
da bock drauf und ich habe schon immer
auf youtube das gemacht worauf ich bock
hab ich finde es ja eigentlich ganz süß
wir müssen hier noch so ein bisschen was
aufräumen das ist hier alles irgendwie
ein bisschen durchlöchert stimmt das
dass wir hier ein schaf schwein und kuh
haben ich will mich komplett vegetarisch
ernähren von daher müssen wir in der
nächsten folge direkt unsere farben
machen wir müssen mit irgend etwas zu
essen kriegen ich will meine tiere nicht
töten egal wo kommt ihr denn her
was ich auf jeden fall der kuh zu liebe
machen möchte einen kleinen grabstein
das hier ist jetzt quasi das grab
für die kuh
namen für die q cells scheißegal
allerdings wird das schaf schorn heißen
papa und schon haben wir jetzt auf jeden
fall von kleinen süßen weg da können
jetzt noch ein paar fackeln an rand
irgendwie machen und vor allem auch
unsere setzlinge mal platzieren weil
irgendwie geht unsere ganze insel ja
doch so ein wenig auseinander gerupft
ausfindig ist einfach auf verdammter
land
[Musik]
also das ging jetzt schnell mit den
diamanten ich baue die diamanten ab
er gab aber eigentlich wenn im wasser
explodieren passiert auch nichts oder
[Musik]
wir haben wir heute einen riesigen plan
und zwar die automatische weizen fahren
der moment der wahrheit meine lieben
freunde habe ich die redstone
verkabelung richtig gemacht dann wird
das wasser hier gleich raus treten kurz
und dann direkt wieder da reinkommen
also wir sind gespannt ich drücke den
knöpfen
[Musik]
ich baue
traumhaus
hier unten ist auf jeden fall alles
fertig also hier kann man reingehen hier
sind denn die ganzen weizen sachen und
so
oben
also das ist mein haus ich weiß nicht ob
jetzt einige vielleicht mehr erwartet
haben aber ich bin jetzt auch nicht der
beste in minecraft
das ist richtig schön wie entdeckte
heute unsere insel
die haben einen pelz be oben ich höre
ich höre
ja wie kriege ich dir jetzt rüber auf
meiner insel ein paar sekunden später
wir haben jetzt eine kuh hier
ja die willicher zu holen ist eine super
welt entdeckungs folge bisher unsere
insel sieht schon schön aus ich bin ein
bisschen stolz auf mich selbst
was bin ich für ein opfer alter das ist
minecraft
[Musik]
hier wurde in die kommentare geschrieben
dass ich doch einen stall für meine kühe
bauen kann weiter hier runter sehr gut
macht er das sehr sehr gut und jetzt
hier rein beide türen offen sagt sascha
kommt her hier rein rhein spaziert rhein
spaziert auch das macht in unsere kasse
da drehen ich suche mir heute einen
neuen freund meiner lieben freunde und
dafür müssen wir erstmal in die höhle
geben meine katze ich weiß nicht ob ich
die mitnehmen sondern die höhle wegen
den krippen ist es ja sinnvoll aber will
nicht dass sie dann stirbt wenn sie
irgendwo hin läuft ich nehme sie aber
einfach mal mit
ich habe zwar
[Musik]
der katze kein eigenes grab machen
möchte und auch keinen richtigen platz
für habe werde ich einfach hier in das
grab von der kuh mit dem rindfleisch nur
noch ein fichtenholz bot einpacken weil
das meine einzige richtige erinnerung
mit der katze war ein stück kies weil
sie dadurch gestorben ist in einen faden
bei katzen in minecraft fäden einfach
klappen
ganz ehrlich kaum erzählen was sich in
diesem bei craft projektes mache jetzt
nämlich allerdings erstmal ein eisen
denn für meinen plan benötigen wir
erstmal keine eisenbahn sondern ganz
normales eisen und daraus auch vier
eisen blöcke
jetzt eigentlich spätestens auch der
größte 0 checker was ich vorhabe ich
weiß nicht wo der fehler liegt ich habe
einen geschnitzten kürbis und muss den
eigentlich hier drauf
der eisen kohle tötet direkt den ändern
wenn das krasse ist dass er halt jetzt
wirklich einfach unsere insel hier
beschützt ich habe meinen neuen freund
erschaffen den golem namens qi
lu ist ein schöner name so carol und
leder benötigen wir um bücherregale
herzustellen und bücherregale benötigen
wir um unseren zauber tisch den ich
irgendwann demnächst machen möchte auf
eine next level zu heben sage ich mal
und dadurch bessere verzauberungen
bekommen zu können ich weiß nicht ob ich
zu viel versprochen habe es hat zwar
sehr lang gedauert und die folge war
wieder ein sehr krasses hin und her aber
ich finde es eigentlich ganz schön der
erste dorfbewohner auf meiner insel
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen
[Musik]
nochmal oder was
wir haben zwölf schildkröteneier hier
wurde geschrieben dass ich einfach
meinen namen stellt nehmen kann und das
jetzt hier reinpacken kann und dann wenn
ich das namensschild beispielsweise
viele war verdammt verschrieben
bild lebt bin ich dumm peter
philipp herr so
richtig
ich nehme mir auch mal glas mit ihr
fragt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich hey
da kann niemand wird das jetzt fragen
ich nehme das glas und baue damit hier
unten die schildkröteneier reihen denn
in der letzten folge sind ja die
schildkröten eier gelegt worden und da
wurde mir geschrieben luca pass auf weil
zombies wollen die eier auch haben ist
so schön sieht's jetzt nicht aus ich
baue heute ein haus für den village
wo sich das ganze jetzt auf jeden fall
von der seite aus so siehts von hinten
aus ich kann mal kurz runter gehen dann
seht ihr dass sich da oben bin jetzt
nicht so richtig aber habe ich auch noch
so ein glas den rhein gebaut das kann
man von innen auf jeden fall ein
bisschen besser erkennen ich gehe jetzt
mal ganz kurz rein wir müssen natürlich
drin ja auch noch alles ein bisschen
schöner machen das ist es dann
allerdings auch schon meine freunde
unser dorfbewohner haus ich finde es
eigentlich ganz süß erste und auch
wichtigste sache die für heute auf dem
plan steht ist dass wir hier in dem
dörflein einen weiteren dorfbewohner
mitnehmen so dass wir unseren paaren
können
[Musik]
meine lieben freunde truppe wäre er
müsse jetzt anschneiden in der nächsten
episode gehen wir in die hölle
[Musik]
ist es die grün
das erste ass
das sieht auch die pumpe unterhält
ich hab doch gerade mit den garten und
die wir denn jetzt
nein nein
[Musik]
ich bin
ich hab's zuschuss nachdem ich ihn etwa
alter könnt ihr alle nichts mehr
einjagen kuba
das ganze jahr antun
haben
[Musik]
so sehen die eigentlich relativ normal
groß aus aber so
und zwar möchte ich trommelwirbel
ich mach das mal an
doch
ich bin auf jeden fall happy ich weiß
nicht ob das klappen wird aber ich will
mir einen see bauen ist schon schön ich
bin richtig happy ich mache hier und da
vorne noch mal das weg was sich da
hingebaut habe denn ich möchte einen
fluss
durch unsere minecraft welt laufen
lassen hier vorne mündet er dann runter
direkt im wasser und hier an die seiten
da können wir uns mal unser zucker
nehmen wir sind 100
hätte ich richtig mit mit einem knochen
in der heutigen episode möchte ich etwas
bauen was mir die kommentare geschrieben
wurde und zwar mir geschrieben luca baut
auf dem baumhaus doch das sieht schon
geil aus ich freue mich will können uns
jetzt das ganze noch mal hier bei nacht
anschauen das sicher drin machen soll
ich hab' ich mach das auch so ein
bisschen verbucht hat es ist halt ein
baumhaus
also darf jetzt auch nicht so christine
wahl aussehen wenn man hier dann
allerdings hoch kommt sieht man schon
überall blätter hier sind eine menge
kisten hier hat man beleuchtung jetzt
geht's endlich an die hundehütte meine
lieben freunde das dann hunderte was
sagst du
ja braucht euch die jetzt eine villa
bauen oder war dass wir heute für ein
ziel haben die willicher insel
die soll nämlich hierhin kommen ich bin
richtig stolz ich bin richtig stolz wir
müssen ja allerdings erst reinigen
das ist nicht nur gehört heute geht's
auf jeden fall ab meine lieben freunde
denn wir werden heute in die bastion
gehen ich weiß nicht was man hier zu
erwarten hat
mehr oder
das ist gar nicht wahr ein überfall
findet statt auf ein einsehen
[Musik]
wir sind voll viele bäume gefällt worden
was ist denn los nur wegen diesen
überfall jetzt ist meine halbe insel
hier kaputt
dollar
alle zusammen oder was
die gelder fließen
sie hatte
sehr gutes ende
ich meine das nicht
eine ganze insel bis zerrupft
[Musik]
alles in allem ein ziel für die heutige
episode minecraft mit luca es ist auf
jeden fall dass unsere insel wieder
schön wie aktiviert wenn ihr so möchte
eine insel reparatur 3.0 guck mal
dass ihr weg ist und so das ist schon
schön aus wir können hier noch kommen
das mache ich auch noch eben alt wie
kommt es überhaupt nicht um die insel
reparatur sondern nur um eine neue
strandliege und ich wollte auch noch mal
eben weil hier beziehen schildkröten
schön ja auch hier drin rum ich wollte
ich starke die schildkröte mit im boot
wie kriegt er mein boot hier raus
[Musik]
kitzbühel
und
schildkröte
ich wollte nur meinen bord zurück wir
benötigen flieder hier vorne wie ich
bereits gerade schon gesagt habe für
magento farbe in den farbstoff und da
fragt ihr euch jetzt auch wahrscheinlich
helmut forster dem agenda farbstoff ich
möchte mir ja eine neue portal insel
bauen und dann möchte ich so ein
bisschen mit glasarbeiten und so weiter
und so fort portal insel meiner welt in
neue portal insel sieht nämlich so aus
wir kümmern uns heute um die village
insel
und wir werden die upgraden auf die
willicher insel 2.0 wir haben hier den
neuen brunnen mit dem schleifstein wir
haben ja einen brunnen mit einer glocke
läuten dann gehen alle rein in ihre
häuser wir haben die farben schöner
gebaut sie haben überall beleuchtung wir
haben hier zwei anstatt der aufpasst er
ist es wirklich wahnsinnig geil geworden
die heutige episode hier durfte in der
letzten episode minecraft mit luke
entscheiden ob hier eine brücke hin soll
oder die seerosenblätter ich glaub die
habens ich mache dir den weg noch mal
weiter dann kann man hier direkt drauf
gehen hier geht es dann quasi weiter
hier geht's weiter das ist fertig sie
todes nice aus also die passt richtig
gut mit rein finde ich dass man mir gut
hingekriegt wir kümmern uns heute
endlich mal um die hier in will so es
sieht wirklich wunderschön hier aus ich
finde es fast schon schön als unsere
insel hinten weil es hier auch ein
bisschen größer ist ich bin es
eigentlich wirklich sehr schön wenn ich
alle rum laufen hier können wir auch
noch ein bisschen was bauen die
schildkröten will und sich schon an ich
freue mich in der heutigen episode habe
ich ein riesiges ziel und zwar möchte
ich ja die bh dort hin bauen
die angeln und bootshütte jetzt sind wir
tatsächlich fertig mit unserer armee
hier vorne ich packe das bot ihm noch
mal eben so ein bisschen schöner in der
parkbucht zack und jetzt kann ich das
ganze noch mal kurz zeigen also hier
vorne sollen dann so angl utensilien
reinkommen wir haben dann hier vorne
seinen kran am start und hier können wir
dann die ganzen fische lagern denn hier
ist ja auch dass fischers netz hier
fordern wir unseren rundgang um das
gebäude herum um hier vorne kann man
reingehen der fischer kann rausgucken
kann mir beim angeln zu gucken oder kann
hier schlafen gehen er hat beleuchtung
er hat kisten am start um die sachen zu
lagern und hier ist dann der perfekte
übergang zu unserem weg hier vorne und
zu unserer insel ich finde es sehr sehr
sehr sehr geil das wird ganz gut
aussehen werden dort auf dem tier in
sind ein kleiner friedhof wäre denn in
der letzten folge der ein oder andere
kann sie eventuell erinnern sind einige
tiere leider verstorben mit denen wir
auf der insel unterwegs waren und zwar
so dass ein bisschen so aussehen
in den friedhof wir haben wir fertig wir
haben die verstorbenen tiere schafe
kaninchen schwein und kuh die er hier
durch die kripo sondern die luft
gegangen sind das haben wir fertig die
liegen hier unten ihr könnt mir
eigentlich auch mal ganz kurz
schweiger sekunde verein binden ihr seht
allerdings auch schon meinen inventar
wie gehabt dass gerade gesehen dass ich
mir eine menge beton gerade noch gemacht
habe den wir halt benötigen für den
leuchtturm dort hinten und damit haben
wir den leuchtturm meine lieben freunde
jetzt auch fertig ich bin extrem stolz
auf das ding egal wie es aussieht es war
eine lange reise ich seh das schon
wieder die typen ankommt ist und selbst
allerdings auch egal meine lieben
freunde denn der erleuchtung denen wir
jetzt so lange gebraucht haben ich
versuche die ganze zeit zu schinden dass
ich jetzt endlich auf meiner insel
angekommen wird sieht so aus
der ist unnormal wild in der heutigen
episode kümmern wir uns endlich um die
kirche die dort hinten ja steht
ja und dafür solltest du auch mal
weggehen sieht sehr sehr sehr sehr geil
aus da bin ich sehr froh darüber und das
passt perfekt mit dem friedhof dahin
allerdings kümmern wir uns heute um
nee
richtig da wurde um die monster falle
jetzt müssen wir noch warten bis ihr die
monster ankommen
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht was ich falsch gemacht
habe ich glaube das liegt daran dass ich
da oben die blöcke kurz weg genommen
habe um dort glas hin zu setzen deswegen
muss ich mich wohl oder übel noch mal
hier rein bewegen drückt das jetzt
einfach mal mit einer spitzhacke hier
rein sodass wir gucken können ob das
alles funktioniert also er geht hier
vorne in den gang rein schießt jetzt
jeden moment nach oben genau wie er
hinterher sagt es nach ganz oben rüber
bis zur anderen seite und hier fällt er
nicht runter weil er mir entgegen
schwimmt wahrscheinlich ne
und jetzt fällt er hier rein
so ein schwert was hier vorne irgendwie
sowas
[Musik]
was soll man machen freunde das ist doch
echt wieder nicht war das tunier
unfassbar leid ich weiß dass das
schaffen riesenteil von diesem projekt
war allerdings ich wollte es auch
einfach nicht töten ist nicht da ich
wollte ihm kurze klaps geben
ich glaube die luke du hast mich nachdem
ich jetzt das schaf aus versehen
umgebracht haben wir müssen uns
irgendwas überlegen freunde es ist es
ist ein bisschen so wie wenn so nach
zehn jahren so ein haustier stirbt ich
möchte dort hinten
dorthin möchte ich das grab für das
scharf drauf setzen da wurde nämlich und
in die kommentare geschrieben luca die
werden wir nur einfach einen schafskopf
dort hinten hinaus und hier auch nochmal
zwei weise wolle das jetzt auf jeden
fall der schafskopf ich doch wenn man
direkt davor steht bei uns nicht so gut
erkennen von der entfernung geht's auf
jeden fall aber deutlich besser klar als
ich jetzt machen wollte war dass ich mir
eben kurz mit den ganzen slums die wir
ja irgendwann letztens in unserer höhle
in unserer mine unten bekommen haben
weil er die ganzen steines pons sind mit
denen wollte ich mir jetzt einige leiden
machen und dann wollte ich das
schweinen die kuh und auch vale wollte
ich mitnehmen auf die trauer insel in
die kirche so dass alle in dem altar in
der kirche mit dabei sind wenn ich die
rede halte
ich das ding zu bluthochdruck
[Musik]
das ist nicht wahr
du warst ein gutes team doch manchmal
warst du auch wenn kleiner stier hast
mich auf zutiefst beleidigt doch uns
alle stets verteidigt ruhe in frieden
schauen wir
[Musik]
hatten zwar keinen namen für dich
dennoch das größer ist beweglich
ein mou von dir war nie eins zu viel
macht ist immer eis am stiel uhr in
frieden
q
das schon irgendwie traurig
das sind die beiden letzten richtigen
tiere auf meiner insel weil das schaf
und die kwo einfach gestorben sind die
hinten kommt er denn der kopf hin
daneben das habe ich mir schon vorgebaut
dass er sehr sehr sehr sehr geil aus
allerdings fehlt mir dafür dass er
wirklich der braune farbstoffe den ich
leider nur aus kakaobohnen bekomme und
kakaobohnen kriegt man nur im dschungel
wir gehen heute endlich in das boot sehr
an monument
ich bin ein bisschen nervös und habe
auch ein bisschen schiss
wer sehr denn papa quelle was ist denn
los alter wasser das den fünf
herstellern die riesig der ist
oh mein gott
aber das spiel wächst vor mir ich habe
eine große diamant rüstung komplett
verzaubert und er hat mich schon meine
hälfte guck mal ich habe
explosionsschutz 132 diamant rüstungen
durch die krise
doch nicht ausdenken
versteckte sich noch hinter der seite
sterben okay ist tot in der letzten
folge hatte ich ja gesagt dass ich einen
namen eigentlich gerne haben möchte für
mein ganzes projekt hier nicht das ist
ja minecraft mit lukas haus einfach raus
ich habe mich wirklich für den namen los
locos entschieden finde ich sehr cool
hat sich irgendwie nach einer
griechischen insel im mittelmeer hat
oder so ist es auf jeden fall der name
von unserer insel hier deswegen habe ich
mir gedacht um diesen namen auch alle
ehre zu erweisen dass wir ein hollywood
zeichen mit dem namen los locos hier
hinsetzen es sich so dass riesig krasse
bauprojekt allerdings seht ihr halt
schon das ist ja geil aussieht fall mit
der spiegelung im wasser ich habe auf
jeden fall ein krasses ziel für die
heutige wieso de und meine lieben
freunde das hat nur etwas mit unserer
trauer insel hier hinten zu tun dsw
bisschen zu traurig ja das kann man
schon so sagen und deswegen habe ich
mich in den kommentaren mal umgesehen ob
er jemand eine idee hatte was wir daraus
noch so machen können da wurde mir das
geschrieben
ein campingplatz
fand ich gut die idee das hier meine
lieben freunde ist unser neuer
campingplatz wir haben hier vorne unser
lagerfeuer wir haben hier einen kleinen
weg durch die natur hin zu unserem sie
wo wir uns an unsere angenehmen können
die ich gerade nicht dabei habe und ein
bisschen angehen gehen könnt hier vorne
es auf jeden fall unser zelt da können
wir uns entspannt rhein zu bieten haben
unser bett wir haben eine werkbank wir
haben genügend
situationen um ihnen die sachen zu
lagern wir können sachen beraten ich
freue mich auf jeden fall uns waren wir
30 braune wolle und wir brauchen genau
30 porno wolle für unseren kopf von der
kuh deswegen ist das todo für die
nächste folge auf jeden fall dass wir
uns auch endlich um den kühkopf kümmern
der dort vorne ja dann stehen soll dass
die da auf jeden fall sehr sehr geil aus
also an der stelle nochmal rest in peace
liebe bleibt für immer in unseren herzen
mir wurde in die kommentare geschrieben
luca sowieso meine freundin für balu
ja ist doch egal also die katze trotz
der frau genommen
aber dass ihr befreundet sein
wie möchten sie noch nicht so richtig
mit dem knochen
[Musik]
ja
ich zeige euch allerdings erstmal wie
die hündin heißen wird und zwar balance
jahre wurden die kommentare geschrieben
aber lulu heißt und valencia ist ähnlich
wie balu aber irgendwie auch weidlich
mit diesem am ende
dann wäre ich auch weiblich aber das ist
schon mal ganz gut mit einem roten
bändchen hier bei uns jager da wir mit
einem blauen bin ich sehr nah als wir
haben doch kein richtiges pferd auf
unserer insel von daher nehmen wir heute
einfach mal ein
[Musik]
nun meldet wir haben fertig möchte hier
vorne hallo papa ich möchte hier vorne
einen luftballon hin weil wir haben
einen ballon oder gott der sie vollends
aus das ist dann auch wirklich unsere
stand hauskeller wir haben ein extrem
extrem geile aussehende toilette und
elektrische schiebetür hier so ein
bisschen der waschbereich wir haben hier
unseren flachbildfernseher wir haben
hier unsere betten haben wir hier unser
wohnzimmer wo man ein bisschen chillen
kann wo man hier hinten dem
sonnenuntergang sieht wir haben hier ein
bisschen depot wir haben hier
ablagefächer für bücher ezb haben hier
unsere
haben habe ich ganz komisch gesprochen
ist war egal wir haben hier vorne unsere
kleine bar bereich und dann haben wir
noch unseren essbereich mit dem schönen
glas tisch wir haben hier unser kleines
feuer die kleine feuerstelle die wir ja
wo wir einige probleme hatten weil das
erst auf der anderen seite sichtbar weit
haben allerdings land einfach mitgezogen
haben unseren pool hier am start ich
habe ja noch diese yacht hier vorne mit
drangesetzt jemand unserem kleinen in
morgarten damit unseren ganzen
eingangsbereich und mit dem schmelzen
und so es ist wirklich sehr sehr sehr
sehr geil ich werde ich mit zunehmender
dauer witzel mit dem ende was er immer
näher kommt zunehmend nostalgischer und
freue mich irgendwie darauf dass es zu
ändert sich jetzt auch in wien jeder
folge ist es auch ein thema das ist bald
vorbei ist es tut mir leid dass ich das
die ganze zeit so thematisiere dieses
thema ja das projekt es bald vorbei und
bleib ich bekomme auch immer die
kommentare von wegen erinnern uns noch
nicht mehr daran dass es bald vorbei ist
aber ich glaube man sollte wirklich gern
mit nach vorfreude darauf zu geben weil
die letzte folge der extremen lang ich
werde ins ende gehen ich hoffe dass sich
schaffe gegen den drachen dann noch mal
ein schönes ende man sieht die credits
am ende in minecraft und damit ist dann
alles vorbei ich freue mich auf jeden
fall auf staffel 2 und ich hab so viele
ideen dass wir zum teil allein mit mods
und so was ich alles vorhabe hier haben
wir allerdings erst mal ein schweinchen
gefunden und ich werde direkt das
namensschild nehmen und das schweinchen
schorsch nennen jetzt haben wir nämlich
schon
okay
so freundlich wie papa komm mal kurz mit
wir müssen ihn jetzt papa vorstellen ich
weiß nicht wo pepper ist und die beiden
freunden sich an
[Musik]
was wir auf jeden fall auch unter die
letzte episode in die kommentare
geschrieben wurde war das hier luca wird
es niemals schaffen dich innerhalb von
nur zwei folgen auf das ende
vorzubereiten deswegen meine lieben
freunde habe ich für heute ich mir
gedacht suchen wir einfach schon mal das
end portal
ich weiß die begeisterung hält sich in
grenzen und läutet jetzt hier
[Musik]
da ist kein platz mehr darauf an und ich
sind auf jeden fall auf dem weg in
richtung ende wir sind wir sind
angekommen wir sind schon da wir sind
schon da leute jetzt das portal jetzt
das portal wir sind schon da wir haben
schon ein paar stellplätze gefühlt haben
auf jeden fall glück gehabt und können
jetzt in die restlichen die ende augen
reinsetzen und dementsprechend das
portal integrieren
[Musik]
ich habe mir das hier gerade 25 minuten
leider angeguckt
mindestens drei mal die tränen es sind
ja einfach zwei tage vergangen in
minecraft ich hab auch ab uns mal nach
links raus glücklich glaube ich hab euch
dass er nicht die ganze zeit so
eingeblendet wie ich denn mir das
angeguckt habe weil das wäre sehr
langweilig gewesen die sache ist
allerdings dass hier kein einziges
phantoms front ist denn laufen ein paar
andere monster rum allerdings niemand
rein exil
schädlich bruder
es war auf jeden fall
unfassbares ich könnte ja mal und in die
kommentare schreiben was eure lieblings
szene war aus dem kompletten besser auf
beziehungsweise generell aus dem
kompletten projekt minecraft mit luca
bei mir waren es auf jeden ich dachte
events haben die aber das ist nur dieses
zuckerrohr bei mir waren es auf jeden
fall diese ganzen creeper situationen
auf jeden fall und ansonsten ein skelett
ist hier noch irgendwer ist niemand ich
sprinte jetzt mal eben schnell rüber zu
meiner insel und schauen ob da nicht
irgendwo noch ein phantom rum schwimmt
ich habe mich wie bereits gesagt gerade
schon so ein bisschen umgeguckt die
sache ist allerdings dass nirgendwo 1
war deswegen hoffen wir mal so ein
bisschen wächst hier
hoffen wir mal so ein bisschen dass wir
vielleicht in der nächsten episode glück
haben denn an der stelle würde ich ihr
heutiger wieso gemeinschaft hier
unterwegs hier
[Musik]
was soll das
und leute von exil
[Musik]
leute treiben
schnell hier um rein einmal kurz ihr zu
und hierzu meine lieben freunde wie
gerade bereits gesagt ich würde an der
stelle die heutigen episode minecraft
mit luca jetzt auch beenden dafür sieht
es lange genug wir sind jetzt locker bei
einer halben stunde mit dem ganzen vor
dem best of und jetzt doch gerade die
ganzen
ihr seht ihn allerdings
das kannst du nicht ausdenken
diese scheiße ihre die ganze perfekt der
gal auf ein witz baum herr fühlt sich
wie zuhause bruder alles gut wurde acht
perfekt um ruhig ja sie papa kommt da
ein bisschen entspannt alles cool was
ich sagen wollte meine lieben freunde
erst mal ein ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz ganz ganz riesiges dankeschön an
tahir der mir dieses best of
zusammengeschnitten hat du bist ein
absoluter ehrenmann mein freund und
natürlich ein riesiges riesiges sagen
wir schon auch an euch in ohne euch wie
dieses komplette projekt mein vater
niemals 100 folgen lang gegangen ich
hätte niemals so lange bock darauf
gehabt ihr müsst euch überlegen seit
einem halben jahr oder seit mehr als
einem halben jahr läuft dieses projekt
schon und jetzt geht es gerade in den
letzten zügen dem ende entgegen ich
hoffe euch hat diese heutige episode und
dieses komplett nostalgie mäßige best
aufgefallen wenn sie das getan hat das
kann einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da abonniert main kanal von klickt
auf die glocke denn die nächste episode
minecraft und luca nicht verpassen
wollte in der nächsten folge kümmern wir
uns dann darum dass wir uns aufs ende
vorbereiten
[Musik]
warum
ist jetzt auch noch im winter von uns
mit zombie
aber gut schreibt mir jetzt gern bitte
ganz ganz ganz ganz viele tipps noch
fürs ende und in die kommentare was soll
ich auf bass verzaubern was muss ich
unbedingt einpacken was soll ich
mitnehmen jetzt läuft auch noch immer
eine kästen können rein schädlich bruder
ich habe euch lieb und ich liebe dieses
projekt und ich bin echt traurig dass es
vorbei geht aber ich freue mich auch
irgendwie auch staffel 2 die teilnehmern
starten wird
[Musik]